el dorado cantina the sponsors of this
next segment are here to wish us a happy
national guacamole
ceo ryan clawson is here to give us a
taste of their award-winning guac so let
me go let me go if you if i can can i
just list your accomplishments really
quick please do okay so we've got best
table side guacamole in the u.s and
canada by yelp
no big deal and then next we have best
guacamole from best of las vegas 2021.
it's uh we're pleased with the guacamole
and the performance the winning winning
awards is always nice
with guacamole clearly absolutely
clearly you guys keep have people coming
back for more every single time so let's
get into it tell us what makes your guac
award-winning look at this
i think first and foremost the
ingredients are fresh we have tomatoes
we have cilantro we have serrano chilies
we have onions the avocados themselves
fresh daily and important part the most
honestly the most important part is the
table side preparation from the show
that you put on the guest gets to kind
of pick and choose what they want in the
guacamole i want a little more of this i
want a little less of that or whatever
it is and we can uh custom make the
guacamole for them tables custom
guacamole that is so cool so let's let's
talk about it what's in this bowl so
i kind of pre-batched this one a little
bit but we have the we have the avocados
we have lime juice we have onions we
have tomatoes cilantro
mix it up here for you get into it
because i'm ready to taste it i didn't
know um guacamole is one of my favorite
things on the planet okay so let's talk
about you know any kind of guacamole
advice you can give to people other than
coming down to el dorado cantina to get
the best guac but what can people do at
home
keep it real
i like that
fresh ingredients always help okay um
you know play with it everybody has a
little bit different palette and you
know you can kind of tweak it the way
you like it and go from there okay
customize it customize at home too so
let's get let's get to tasting while you
tell us about that's a try the
current special that el dorado cantina
what's going on how's the vibe there so
people really know what they're walking
into so the vibe is fantastic we have
three different locations uh we have one
in the southwest we have one near the
las vegas strip and then we have one in
tavoli village summerlin somewhere great
for everybody yeah and all of them are a
little bit different the one in the
southwest is a little more gaming bar
ask we have sports viewings there all
the time with the great food and then
tivoli is probably the most proper
restaurant
the biggest restaurant great energy
great food you know great vibes we do a
lot of cool promotions a cool spot yeah
wow and then the one near the strip was
the original kind of the proof of
concept um we recently gave it a
makeover oh good looks fantastic but
same great food the original food the
original kitchen and uh again you're
right next to the strips okay well you
mentioned the original food and kitchen
so really quick just kind of tell us
what we're eating there besides the guac
well i have um
i mean a little bit of everything you
got tacos you got burritos you got i
mean we specialize in especially tacos
we have lobster tacos filet mignon tacos
surf and turf fajitas um
carnitas carne asada
happy national guacamole day everybody
stop by el dorado cantina and thank you
to eldorado cantina for sponsoring this
segment they have three locations in the
valley
i know oh really okay yeah you're you're
loving your own guacamole i do it often
i do it often for me for more
information just visit
eldoradocantina.com